ok marina ce la puoi fare benvenuti in
un nuovissimo video mi presento io sono
pinky blitz i gleeks ho fatto un test
per scoprire qual è il mio nome da
unicorno era da tantissimo che non
faceva un video è ultimamente ho
comprato delle cosine sono stata anche a
miami a capodanno quindi ho fatto un
pochino di shopping anche lì ho comprato
qualcosina con i saldi qui a milano e
soprattutto sono andata una svendita un
mese fa e mi sono dimenticata
assolutamente di far vedere cosa ha
comprato una svendita di un brand molto
molto famoso iniziamo subito proprio da
questo brand molto conosciuto alcuni di
voi che mi seguono su instagram si
ricorderanno che avevo detto che ero
andata una svendita speciale ma non mi
volevo ancora dire di cosa per insomma
lasciarvi con la suspance e poi è
passato un mese diciamo come sono
dimenticata e quindi e arrivato il
momento di far vedere cosa comprate
soprattutto svelarvi il brand iniziamo
proprio dalla svendita di moschino
allora è stata una svendita sofferta
vero dico avete presente i love shopping
la scena della svendita invece le
ragazze che si davano per i capelli
urlavano in preda al panico dello
shopping
ecco più o meno pochi ma
con differenza che invece di starci
forse uno è che sono stato a 5 ore
perché comunque volevo provare tutto ben
eccetera eccetera
alla fine ho scelto i capi che vi sto
per far vedere perché erano quelli che
mi stavano meglio e di cui avevo più
bisogno quindi anche alle svendite
bisogna comunque ragionare non comprare
cose che possono mettere mai partirei
subito con uno degli acquisti che ho
preferito appena l'ho visto me ne sono
innamorata soprano di questo fantastico
cappotto mi è piaciuto da subito perché
mixava il classico con il moderno con
questi inserti in pelle gridavano un
tocco di aggressività più e soprattutto
pena l'ho provato mi fidavo la
perfezione sembrava cucito appunto su di
me e quindi dei mio non c'è bisogno di
guardare altro l'ho trovato è mio
infatti l'ho preso secondo acquisto
della senza di moschino è questa giacca
che io ho adorato perché è super
elegante ma allo stesso tempo a questa
chiusura che ricorda molto le i chiodi
di pelle modello bikers e soprattutto è
corta come piace a me io ho soltanto
jeans pantaloni e gonne a vita alta
quindi questa è perfetta perché arriva
proprio sopra la vita da ve la faccio
vedere faccio vedere come mi fissa
perché secondo me di titta benissimo poi
magari mi sta male quindi a voi giudici
magari mi tolgo questo che ti faccio un
po più la seriosa notate la bellezza
l'eleganza può essere usata sia la sera
sia di giorno con un look un po più
sportivo insomma arriviamo quindi al
terzo ed ultimo acquisto che a
differenza degli altri due è più un
capriccio perché non è che si può
mettere proprio tutti i giorni ma era
troppo troppo poco sobrio per lasciarlo
lì era proprio la sobrietà prima di
tutto e lo anche indossato in montagna
quindi secondo me alcuni di voi avranno
visto nella foto comunicato in montagna
lo volete vedere non lo volete vedere a
un bellissimo colbacco sobrio con
scritto moschino
perché in caso non volessi farlo sapere
che di moschino
lo dice direttamente il cappello quindi
però questo era il capitolo svendita di
moschino per quanto riguarda i saldi qui
a milano come al solito trovato poco o
niente nel senso che andavano i negozi e
mi piaceva tutto ciò che faccia parte
della nuova collezione
l'unica cosa sono riuscita a comprare
con i saldi quest'anno è un'altra giacca
nera però aspettate non partite subito
col pensare al comprato due jack quali
no perché sono molto diverse adesso ve
lo dimostrerò questa infatti è una
fantastica gioca compreso damage e a
differenza di quella di moschino ha un
taglio più dritto quindi da uomo e non
ha il cinturino ma i bottoni e
soprattutto è più lunga quindi adesso la
proverò vi farò vedere che insomma non
arriva qui sopra la vita ma è più lunghi
na
io la trovo top perché perfetta sia
sopra un jeans e un top o magari anche
la scarpa la sneaker oppure anche con la
tuta la tutta bella larga foto e magari
una scarpa col tacco molto casual moto
street style
stavo pensando che questo video lo è
potuto intitolare al video all
giacche nere perché perché dopo le due
già che vi opera fatto vedere mi sono
ricordata che ne ho comprato un altra
sempre nera cioè questa che però a
differenza delle altre più che un blazer
è un chiodo solo che invece di essere in
pelle e velluto nero come potete notare
con questi dettagli bottoncino e
cerniere oro quindi l'ho visto ha detto
che è mia e l'ho provata mi stava bene
quindi ho detto ok è definitivamente
adesso vi faccio vedere siete contenti
che riprovo le cose perché ogni tanto
quando sempre con faccio i video al
milite marina ma non li provi mai noi
vogliamo vederli
facciamo anche un po cioè quanto è
carina col cartellino cash da quello e
tocco di classe e quanto è carino
ragazzi il ramo e con questa soffrissi
ma coroncina io passerei agli acquisti
di miami infatti quest'anno acquistata
miami insieme al cerchino da un corno
che ha utilizzato prima e nello stesso
negozio che era uno di quei negozi ad
ora ci sono trucchi cianfrusaglie
cecchettini collanine beach hotel quando
proprio detto passi due ore compri di
tutto ho acquistato 260 ciglia finte
in america è pieno di ciglia finte e poi
a milano ci sono un negozio dove vado a
comprarle o vabbè da sephora in america
ovunque voi anche al supermercato
troverete ciglia finte e sono pazzesche
quindi non provate un po poi quando
ritornerò farò la scorta ma in questo
stesso negozio trovato questa cosa che
io trovo geniale
io uso beauty blender lo sapete l'avete
visto anche nei miei tutorial e cosa
succede per non sporcarlo dove lo
conservo nel suo nella sua confezione di
plastica dove insomma lo trovate quando
lo comprate
peccato che si secca ovviamente essendo
chiuso e non prendendo aria quindi che
come ho trovato io in questo negozio il
contenitore per il beauty blender in
silicone proprio della marca beauty
blender poi infilate qua il vostro letto
il post bt blender e verrà conservato ma
soprattutto si potrà a reggere il vano
contenitore in modo tale che non si
rovini e non si secchi io lo amo lo
aveva quando vi state poi mio questo
invece l'ho preso nel negozio di
havaianas salvo si è comprato un paio di
ciabattine e io gli avevo gia quindi ho
dato un'occhiata in giro e ho visto
quest'anno da qui ha detto no vabbè ma è
quello che penso io
ragazzi questa è una borsettina il
silicone per la spiaggia
io non so voi ne ho parlato con è detto
che lui non sapeva l'esistenza questa
volta ivi comprese tutte le estati un
piccolo beauty case oppure uso le
custodie dei costumi sapete quelle di
plastica e ci metto dentro il telefono i
soldi e quando va a fare una passeggiata
in spiaggia ovviamente comporta tutta
una borsa da spiaggia porto solo quel
borsellino dico le cose più importanti
però tipo a miami mi è capitato che mi
cadesse in mare e se bagnato tutto
quindi ho rischiato di perdere il
telefono e soprattutto se non lo
prendevo in tempo rischiavo che
arrivasse in italia direttamente via
mare quindi quando visto questo mi sono
illuminata perché ovviamente
impermeabile quelli che può accadere
ovunque anche in mare
e non succede assolutamente nulla l'ho
scelto di questo colore perché di solito
in estate mi faccio lunghe di questo
colore quindi coppa d'oro me c'era con
le mie unghie
passiamo all'abbigliamento soffrissimo
acquistato miami proprio un tocco di
sobrietà non indifferente partendo da
questo che sito ho preso da forever
twenty one
l'ho visto ho detto va bene io con
questo diventerò donatella versace
probabilmente infatti l'ho preso e top
adoro oro nero
figuriamoci poi sempre la forever twenty
one ho preso questo completo pazzesco in
velluto prugna che colore è questo in
puglia c'è il panta col a vita alta e
poi c'è il suo toppino quindi pancia di
fuori in velluto non si capisce bene in
quali stagione dovrei mettere ovviamente
inverno perché d'estate velluto no con
il blazer sopra tacco e ciao fashion
week a chi sul gol ma proposito di
fashion week di eleganza vi volevo far
vedere questo cross sempre di velluto
leopardato con lo sfondo rosa quindi
proprio una sciccheria veramente da
ghetto che però mi piace un sacco
ultima cosa che ho preso la forever
twenty one tanti di voi ahimè non
conosceranno questo film è questa t
shirt questo croft hoc per che ha
l'appoggio di fuori di cruel intentions
allora io so che voi andate fuori di
essa per gossip girl ma vi devo svelare
un segreto che avete su un sacco così
prima di gossip girl
c'è stato un film cioè cruel intentions
che era praticamente il l'antenato di
prossimi 15 erano più o meno le stesse
dinamiche tutti ricchi eccetera eccetera
bellissimo sono avete visto non potrò
vedere invece dai urban outfitters ho
trovato questa che adoro
mi mancava di tartan e o di tutti i
colori in causa il giallo e mi sta molto
da ricreato il video di fancy di gas e
le ha ecco ansa offensiva uguale molti
anni 90
concludiamo con victoria's secret a
miami e ovviamente c'era negozio ma
soprattutto c'erano i saldi
non ho mai visto così tanto panico in un
negozio proprio la gente impazzita le
cose effettivamente costavano molto poco
ho comprato questo modica sempre in
saldo provocato anche lì 15 euro
penso di usarlo per il prossimo video
dei cattivi della disney tutorial di
halloween
perché proprio in the mood molto molto
sve luccicoso per 20 appena lo prendi lo
tocchi alla mano piena di brillantini
quindi per coloro che vogliono brillare
con e senza body ultimo acquisto ultimi
acquisti questi due beauty case
io sono piena di beauty case
salgo mi aveva regalato mitica di
victoria secret comodissimo che sia
appenderlo con l'appennino pulita
viaggio è pazzesco uno dei regali più
azzeccati di sempre e ne ho tanti altri
varie marche eccetera eccetera i beauty
keys non bastano mai
sapete quanto i deputati 5 euro l'uno
qui a milano forse costano 50 euro
utilissimi sono praticamente gli
abilitati potete usare anche
semplicemente così senza le bustine
dentro mettendoci tutti dentro
oppure potete dividere quindi magari poi
mettete i pennelli qui le tinte labbra
eccetera eccetera sono super comodi e
soprattutto in valigia ne potete di
potete utilizzare anche tutti e due e
mettete così e avete tutti i vostri
tutti a portata di mano
mi sono appena resa conto che ho fatto
tutto il video con l'etichetta che si
vedeva e grazie eduardo per avermi
informato lui l'ha fatto apposta poteva
tutto il video così in video finisce qua
spero tanto che vi siano piaciuti i miei
acquisti fatemi sapere con un commentino
qui sotto
cosa avete preferito e ci vediamo al
prossimo video all
vi mando un bacione e ricordatevi sempre
questa volta lo cambio finale la
sobrietà prima di tutto
[Musica]